To summarize, the performance results
for Flash show the following.
When the data is in cache, the basic
SPED model performs much better than
the AMPED Flash,
because it doesn't require the test for
memory presence,
which was necessary in the AMPED Flash.
Both SPED and the AMPED Flash
are better than the multi-threaded or
multi-process models, because they don't
incur any of the synchronization or
context switching overheads that
are necessary with these models.
When the workload is disk-bound,
however, AMPED performs much better than
the single-process event-driven model,
because the single process model blocks,
since there's no support for
asynchronous I/O.
AMPED Flash performs better than both
the multi-threaded and the multi-process
model, because it has much more
memory efficient implementation,
and it doesn't require the same level of
context switching as in these models.
Again, only the number of concurrent
I/O bound requests result
in concurrent processes or
concurrent threads in this model.
The model is not necessarily suitable
for every single type of server process.
There are certain challenges
with event-driven architecture.
We said, some of these can come from the
fact that we need to take advantage of
multiple cores and we need to be able to
route events to the appropriate core.
In other cases,
perhaps the processing itself,
is not as suitable for
this type of architecture.
But if you look at some of the high
performance server implementations
that are in use today, you will see
that a lot of them do in fact use
a event-driven model,
combined with a synchronous I/O support.